oh you know what this is for pride month
how is it okay cool yeah
is it pride month no okay I don't know
what's wrong with this dude all right
that always comes up we'll put this up
in June that's why we're in purple there
you go we've Justified it but then
Target got in trouble you might get
in trouble well
I'm better than Target
take it away Roxy citizens of the reject
Nation it is time
is that how you pronounce it I don't
know we're watching an awesome Finnish
movie today at least we hear it's great
it's an action movie that we know
literally nothing about Greg says he
hears good things I've never even heard
of the film at all I heard they kill
Nazis and I said Jew girl we're watching
this together I walked up today and you
said super Juice
I love a Nazi killing movie if you think
that I just did the best intro of all
time leave a like throughout this entire
thing just hit that like button comment
button hit the like button you're
carrying it yeah she's doing really well
and if you want to see the entire thing
if you want to watch the full length of
it all go over and be a super sexy
reject over on patreon yes Greg she did
all the things to hit all the points
Roxy Super Jew can do an intro
it's true
[Music]
YouTube I need to tell you everything in
this movie fake so you know it's not
okay that's the finished word that
cannot be translated white-knuckled form
of courage and unimaginable
determination oh do we have Susu
Manifesto when all hope is lost oh nice
now we got still got some hope oh okay
44 a heart of Nazis Warren's in 45 so we
got some time the second world war is
coming to an end this is an English
Finland and the Soviet Union have signed
the Moscow Armistice which decrees that
Finland must disarm the Nazis and drive
them out of Lapland yes I'm following
the Nazis destroyed all roads Bridges
and towns deep in the wilderness of
Lapland there is a man who has decided
to leave the war behind him okay but was
he a Nazi I don't think so
this is exciting I haven't even seen the
trailer for this I have like no idea
what's gonna happen what is he searching
for do you think like
I'm not I don't have words today I know
what he's doing
gold curdles
I think that's what they are
because we just saw it yeah but that's
what they did back then
it's old oh man it's like a pulpy film
with a dog or a sheep a dog
100 positive is a dog
sheep's making weird noises back there
[Laughter]
do you know much about planes like if I
said are those b-17s would you be able
to identify yes
yes I would
damn what a great shot he doesn't even
look up yeah because that's how
frequently that's happening
man this has such good atmosphere I
don't know much about finland's part in
World War II or the way that they've set
this up then what good are you in this
video Roxy
it was just interesting like you know
you hear of the big ones yeah
uh the war took his wife Fury Rising
that is so much gold
oh that's a gold mine right there man
jackpot baby
imagine how you would feel In This
Moment you'd forget that you had a dead
wife this whole time
remember how excited he was with the one
pellet he's got hope but then they said
when your hope is lost sisu
yeah and the Nazis don't give a [__]
about his hope
oh look at it I'm ready to protect my
gold just because you've left the war
behind doesn't mean the war has left you
nice
I love how there's been no dialogue this
entire time
whoa homeboy was cut up maybe they took
one of his organs oh yeah good call
as a haunting image right there you
think they found it and they're like we
gotta shoot that
maybe chapter two the Nazis
I love the old school Western War Vibe
this is going for yeah but that pulpy
zest you don't see a lot of Western
World War II style things
it's true yeah rocking my brain for them
way more World War One Western stuff
oh damn it has all that gold on him
right now you know they're taking it
what a really long Dreadful passing
[__]
he's riding to his death anyway what
does that mean
build up of Horrors here literally
entering Death Valley where do you think
he is trying to go to sell the gold
that's my best guess too yeah
I feel like they're gonna kill this dog
because they think it's a sheep yeah
it's a sheep killer where you think
you're going old man there's nothing
down there be made sure of that
what do you got there oh no this stuff
is a gold miner oh man take a look at
this
I'm a rich boy
what the [__]
of gold
get down on your knees Grandpa
oh my God
we got gold
thank you Wowie
talk about a breaking an actor holy [__]
nicely done man
those other Nazis are about to show up
ugh
damn way to go Gramps
oh my God
that's what I'm talking about Roxanne
it's just we know what the next thing is
so I'm not I can't celebrate yet you
know they're on their way back I know
it's going to be 50 minutes ago I can't
wait I feel like he's gonna walk out
alive well otherwise the movie would be
over no I mean by the end of the movie I
think it's just gonna be him killing a
bunch of Nazis
they're gonna go find him where's the
dog
what happened was golden it was on the
horse
you're gonna tell him about the gold
uh he had a piece on him
he knows
wow
please don't shoot the horse I think
they're going too please don't
I think they did shoot him maybe
oh
oh that is not cool man
[Music]
that's good he's walking to his death
means
ah gross
who really don't like animal deaths
they're coming for the gold this might
be insensitive but he has to get up and
hide the gold in his like butt and his
CH like he needs to like keep some of
the gold on him yeah it's obviously not
what he's thinking about but you're
about to lose all of it
how is he gonna make it out of this
alive he loves his that's his pet though
too
oh [__] his Gold's all scattered yeah
uh
that's where the sea suit quality comes
and I hope we're saying that right
I think I said sissue
you might be right we could have looked
it up on Google beforehand
what are you gonna do with that
no
smart man not really
he's hiding in the shadows in the Smoke
hell yeah
where is he gonna go and I take it back
you're right I don't mean not really
it's just like was
oh
all right two totally different
experiences you're like so wrapped up
for the
turmoil of the situation and I'm like oh
this is gonna be some cool action we're
gonna get it
huh
this is so impressive how they conducted
this with like no dialogue for so much
of this is not dialogue driven I love it
it's like a visual thrill I take
everything back he is so impressive this
is like giving him enough time to what
is a mine what's not
oh my God
[Laughter]
so did he pick up a mine and throw it I
guess he picked up a mine and threw it
you
and you
on the sides of the road now
I
shouldn't you guys be looking down are
you idiots
Nazis
[Applause]
look down
pick two of our female friends and bring
them to me
oh that's cruel and some roll
oh he's not gonna let he's gonna give up
his gold for them he's not gonna let
them die right I mean because his wife
you
yeah all right
look how effective of a shot this is I
know this is there's some just amazing
shots in this Big Mate
they must be so buried that you can't
even yeah see it why are they tied
together
how many chapters do you think there are
seems to be one every 10 minutes I would
say nine chapters eight chapters eight
chapters he has given us orders and head
to Norway from Finland immediately did
you tell him he just killed seven of our
men I did he thinks we were lucky why
of his number they know who he is now it
is like a John Wick situation yeah he
was a Finnish Commando the most feared
in his unit
the boogeyman he fought in the winter
War lost his home and his family to the
Russians
ah okay but it looks like he has over
300 Russian kills so he's most ruthless
when he is in this position is this
based on a true story I highly doubt it
they gave him a name they call him
koshai the immortal
we are not turning back we are losing
the war in a few months this all will be
over for us when we get back they will
hang us all he's desperate to that cold
is our way out desperate because of what
he's done no [__] they're gonna hang you
it's smart to set it at this specific
time that way it justifies the villain's
motive I just like the writing of the
choice of that like yeah okay it's more
than just I want gold yeah yeah this is
a chance for him to survive too yeah and
it can't be because you care about your
men and Vengeance it's like we wouldn't
believe that yeah you only care about
yourself I bet that there is Merit to
some of this the legend of this guy I
don't know but there was gold miners at
the time Russia and sort of the most
some of the most ruthless
punch it
or throw some dirt on it
is it stuffing it damn was that dirt I
think so what do they say you're
supposed to do gunpowder right oh hey it
might be right
is this dog still alive I I think his
dog ran off but definitely oh yeah yeah
the dog lives
I love this sheep how fast the Sheep is
going it looks like a soft coat of
Wheaten Terrier couldn't tell it was a
dog now you have a very specific breed
in mind it's a little wider than soft go
to wheat Interiors there are sheep
breeders
they're gonna see him right now right
I would love it if this guy does not
talk the entire movie
nicely done
oh boy
what is his game plan here I mean it's
working for now
oh
to make them run out of gas I know oh no
so that he masks his smell I think he's
gonna blow it up
Oh no you're probably right
oh
no
oh [__] oh [__]
release the dog no how many animal
deaths are gonna be
the [__] is he doing he's covered in
gasoline I guess
see
you just set yourself on fire
what a crazy strategy he's holding on to
the gold to keep himself down
what's his plan to outlast them
what a shot that's gorgeous he should be
a little mermaid
hot cake
oh
no get midi gold
he's gonna kill him
I love this guy this is unbelievable
this movie come out this year yeah
set his head back up oh he's breathing
the air oh yeah
the oxygen from what I don't know oh my
sure there's a thing to explain it into
the comments I don't know
I'm rolling with it I mean I guess we
all have oxygen in our whoa that was
insane
there's oxygen in our blood
I don't know I think in his throat like
his lungs oh yeah that makes more sense
the pipes I don't I don't know you don't
know how it works guys I don't know with
Biology in your air pipes
this effect of seeing the blood in the
water is unbelievable
it's like oh I just love how terrified
they are he's under water he's gonna
pull down the
cut the string it's so fun
spooky
that dude didn't like German at all he's
gonna flip it and then he's gonna be use
the boat as a shield and breathe air as
the boat is upside down like Captain
Jack Sparrow yep one more meter and I'll
have you shots
this version is punishable by Death
just gave her a man an opening yeah why
would
what
desertion is punishable by Death
yeah yeah
stream kinetic visuals
no
hey
oh [__] what are they gonna do
use them
find me a boat
why
because of scorched Earth Greg obviously
it's like the best action characters
your protagonist is the smartest person
in the room and he's so so is the
smartest person in this room in the
universe he could have defeated World
War II for us but that's why you and I
don't know what he's gonna do yeah and I
like how you have to just watch him do
it yeah you have to like play along and
go what is he about doing he's gonna use
the bonus The Shield of that thing it
was like wrong every time rocks
yeah
holy [__] this is Hometown is I think
this is supposed to be the town where he
was going to it's like what is gold good
for when you have nothing left
he hasn't spoken a word this whole time
huh no well we got a couple grunts I
can't believe they have his dog sheep
thank you
is this flashback or is this yeah I
think it's PTSD
oh that's neat
just in such Adoration of the uh stylish
flourishes that this movie does because
like they just warp his actual
surroundings and throw in some sound
design instead of like cutting to
footage it's really clever this script
for this must have looked so strange
must be written and directed by the same
person must be no way did a director
take this script and make this this
genius
whole Vision oh no he's being baited oh
what did he they ask him for oh no
dynamite oh
they're gonna hang him and he's gonna
live he's gonna find a way to get down
his neck will just Snap It Off
how will he get out of this because he's
got that thing on his back but his hands
are tight yeah but it's him
he leaves him a piece
for your troubles
hmm
seem masterfully faking his own death
yeah
okay now
oh my God oh my God is he really gonna
do that oh
oh
you know this is worries I'm sorry
he's got to get the dog to climb up him
and
chew off the Rope yeah or
nament
I'm having a hard time speaking right
now I know
you're perturbed at the moment
oh good good
oh that's a benefit
oh my God out of all the gore stuff that
that is the one that's bothering me the
most
oh no
I thought it was a finish plane
[Applause]
oh he's gonna totally hijack that plane
legs around them
they're probably so confused where the
dog came from
this son of a [__] is still alive
and shoot the dog too oh hell no
oh
he had it easy
oh man don't give up you need to feed
your dog too
what's the realization that this guy
knows where the other guys are that he
can maybe take the uniform and go in a
plane yeah
keep your eye on the prize man go keep
your eye on the prize
God
these wounds it's like I [__] about a
paper cut
oh
some really good makeup
he's just so brutal oh my God this guy
walked again it's the worst thing I've
seen in this war the plane is ready what
about the rest of our Squad we don't
need us to get to Norway the boys have a
crate full of booze and a truck full of
[__] I'm sure they'll figure
something out they're like rappers
I feel like that woman's gonna murder
some people yeah she should and then she
should marry suzu instantly
what is CeCe's name oh I haven't even
asked myself that question this whole
movie yeah
this is the plan
this is something else I've been so back
and forth with is this movie dubbed or
not but then I like look at their mouths
and they're speaking English speaking
English yeah
the pilot has been hanged
that's my rope what
that's the Rope I used to hang coffee
with how do you know that well we'll
give that to them
he's back
what's so funny do you [__] really
think you have succeeded they'll just
keep coming back do you really believe
that he's Immortal no he just refuses to
die cool I love her
this is not about who's the strongest
this is about not giving up and he won't
worry so funny is that you your
boyfriend
and everything that is left of your
sorry ass company are already dead
I was just working on getting him his
gold back what oh wow
thank you
marry me if they've gotta fall in love I
understand that's not the purpose but
this is my purpose Greg
oh
give her her power
wow that's a lot of guns yeah
six chapters we were close no I think
there's gonna be an aftermath yeah it's
gonna be seven chapters then yeah yeah
I'm back
whoa
awesome
God I love this music
give the middle finger
oh damn
oh my God
what's up they're all dead
we are almost there step on it that was
the best you gotta know to give up give
up the goldfish
that wasn't a bad strategy on the Nazism
he got up there fast but it was
pointless
of course this guy could put up a fight
oh is the other guy up there now dude no
it's just him I think I saw a stunt
double at one point
you're such a dumbass that's when you've
shoot him he's singing more gold for me
I hope it's the lemon that's him oh
let's go shy
they totally have the upper hand on it
they just don't take it
he leaves him to live now the woman are
gonna come though
yeah yeah
The Suicide Squad
better run [__]
[Laughter]
that guy was so good we just had to make
sure he was really unlikable before he
dies why did he just shoot that guy more
gold for them yeah but did the other guy
even know about the gold of course he's
been saying we need the gold who's still
that's everyone no the other guy yeah
but he's the three of them have been in
the same proximity the whole time oh
that guy he probably would have at some
point
get on the plane
wow he's really on this plane he hooked
it and he's climbing you see him
still down there he's not
God the strength
it's actually kind of a terrifying shot
it's ridiculous as it is it's pretty
scary that's some Tom Cruise stuff
that's why he didn't kill him he needs a
pilot ah
it's like a more believable Fast and
Furious scenario
we might have a problem oh my God
foreign
kill him
ouch
has always happened with the finale bad
guys come on kick his ass
why isn't he why
thank you
oh my God
that's the most I've ever seen an action
hero get messed up in a first movie
unless this is just a one-off
[Music]
whoa it looks like they really blew
something up there
[Laughter]
[Music]
I even forgot what the myth name they
gave him is like
oh that is also dead something like
Invincible all right
forget about Wikipedia
oh he's gotta jump out of the plane
where's your gold
he's carrying it okay nope I'm wrong
he's looking for it right now
Roxy you idiot he's caring come on
after all this he's not going to get his
gold oh he's strapping in
[Applause]
I mean sure why not maybe he was looking
for a parachute not for his gold oh yeah
you're right a little bit of exposition
Finland would go a long way sometimes he
can't speak he can't give us any
Exposition for my American Noggin I
can't keep up with your visual
storytelling the fact that this man is
gonna walk out of this is unbelievable
a foreign language this must be the
Finnish people right
that's cool
must be do you think it's the last one
[Laughter]
face sweet digs man
I hope he has a crazy American accent I
don't know if we're gonna hear him I
hope we don't but if we do I hope it's
American what consulate is this where
are we I don't know other places outside
of California
I think it's London the last letters
were nkki
I'd like to cash this gold please
[Applause]
it's awesome
heaters
[Laughter]
we already dressed by the same guy here
or a fascinating pulp film I think it
was a Finnish Bank
it seems that way
well [__] Roxy's stryer I always said
Roxanne Roxanne Roxanne Roxanne Roxanne
I did hours and hours of research
before doing our review right now and we
have discovered that sisu is inspired by
a real life figure
um you know how to pronounce his name
oh man you might just nailed that I
don't know oh no go back what happened
anyway it's a Finnish person with the
nickname being the white death believed
to have killed over 500 enemy soldiers
during the winter war and he's inspired
by Rambo from First Blood I could
totally see those Inspirations so yeah
that was crazy though no I like how it
plays into like the whole legendary
aspect of it all uh that was a really
fun beautiful creative film how'd you
feel how does it feel can you enjoy a
good pulpy War action movie or do you go
like ah this is is having fun with
something that's a little too real I
thought that movie was amazing oh yeah I
think it's a totally fair question
especially like
um you know most World War II movies are
um Holocaust movies or like very
Jewish focused as which makes sense
um and I have a lot I have a hard time
watching a lot of them because
um I lost family in in the Holocaust and
also just as my connection of being
Jewish and so it's interesting a lot of
times when you think about the war you
don't think about all of the
implications and effects of all
different country I mean it's there's a
reason it's called World War II right
but you know it's a it's a whole [__]
world war and
um I when we started it I was like wow I
don't know anything about
finished representation in the war like
what happened to their people or what
they were and you see how greatly
affected obviously this isn't a
documentary but like the the
communities are affected people's
families are killed everything is like
burnt to a crisp and
on both sides they're thinking about
like how do you live after this like
trying to figure out how to have life
after this so because of that I didn't
feel like like when you're asking do I
have a hard time watching something that
is more pulpy or action-packed like this
it didn't feel disrespectful to the war
like I do have a hard time with movies
that it feels like that they're making
light of it I didn't feel like this made
light of the situation at all it just
showed a different side of it and also
uh in this for a similar reason that I
love and glorious bastards it's like you
want to see the Nazis get theirs like
you want you want to see their asses
handed to them and this movie does that
you know like you you just want to see
you want to see there they get their um
yeah how do you spell it come Muppets I
don't know how to spell it I've never
tried there's no r in it yeah
there might be now I don't know I don't
know I often had me question things that
I shouldn't question you know what I
mean though where it's like this wasn't
like oh what the f that's rude it was
like yeah get them and a different side
of things and just yeah I really really
enjoyed this movie I love that I didn't
know any of the actors I love that I
didn't know anybody working on it it
felt like you were able to just get
fully sucked into this world I think
multiple times throughout it we were
taken away just in awe of the way it
looked and the way it sounded like they
just did an excellent job with this yeah
I felt like it was a transport of
experience I really felt like I was
planted there it was a really great like
mood it was a mood piece as well and
that's a really good point that you made
actually about how it doesn't feel
disrespectful to it like they don't take
the piss out of the knots about what the
kind of Horrors they dealt them like the
kind of fear that they did impose as
well I really did I think that's because
they did lead into like the dread and
the horror prior to like cool action to
kind of show you like no and then you
have the the female prisoners as well uh
being you know dragged along here
showing like no they a lot of cruel acts
that are reminding you of it versus yeah
undercutting it in any way you know and
to build up this like Mythos around this
guy who uh because the Nazis were even
though they were at this time where they
were losing or like on the verge of
losing they build up the Mythos of this
this Legend Who
has been able to like kill so many
people and
I forgot where I was going with that I
was going
Roxy you're very smart you're saying
yeah because you're a genius so glad
that you're on this channel and I was
saying Greg thanks so much for seeing my
value and my worth uh yes that is that
was part of where I was going to
before something I told Roxy you're
leading this because I am very lethargic
today you said you were getting lost in
the movie like you you were able to
really fully get lost in it which I
think there's something to your point
that I was actually saying about
um you said that it wasn't disrespectful
to it which I was talking about I guess
they know how to do this as great blend
of like hiding fantasy mixed with not
under underscoring the reality Horrors
just I was trying to say a fancier
version of what you said and I should
just get this I think that you nailed it
you crushed it um I another movie that I
love is JoJo rabbit did you ever see
that yeah I thought it was so so great
and they did such a great job and it
does show that like you can really
tackle any topic as long as you kind of
have a point of view on it and you want
to and you are being respectful of that
topic and it's like I I feel like for
this they gave us exactly what we wanted
which was you're right they the stakes
are not are the Nazis going to win or
lose like we know this isn't this is in
Fall of 44 they know that they're on
their way out they're desperate and that
almost makes the movie more enjoyable
because usually you're dealing with
Nazis in the height of their power and
they've got like they're swinging their
big dicks
but they think that you know whatever
that expression is swinging their people
anyway swords is it swinging there
whatever you know I'm talking about but
you don't know
okay I think you were trying to say Greg
I'm so happy to be on this channel
after everything you've done here
but usually we're dealing with these
these Nazis that like they think that
they're about to [__] pulverize and
here we're dealing with desperate Nazis
and that's like yeah kind of more a more
fun place to watch because you're like
all right this guy is this guy is not
only about to kick him when they're down
as they [__] should be but he's about
to give these women the power to do it
back to them what's been done to them a
thousand times
um and even like the little implications
of with the gun like opening her legs I
mean you know that these women are being
[__] tortured by the these guys uh
and they're making them walk through the
Minefield yeah like they don't look at
them as people
um and so completely dehumanized so to
to see this and see every single Nazi in
this movie Die not one of them lives it
was like you know they introduced like
40 Nazis and we killed every one of them
yeah we killed them at the gas station
we killed them in the plane we killed
them and the tanks in the tanks we
killed them like literally every stop
you know there was no no Nazi Left Alive
yeah um so that was like yeah every one
of you guys who's gonna come up against
this man and I also like that like we
got a little bit of his backstory but we
didn't need
like how you feeling the blank yeah you
fill in the blanks he's wearing his
wedding ring the girl in the truck talks
tank talks about the legend of him that
he lost everything you get it like they
showed it enough we didn't need some
monologue like the year was
1940 and you know we got yeah yeah
a lot you have to keep it mysterious if
you know him too well that it actually
would make it less believable because
this has to be a fantasy of what we're
watching take place who was this guy's
now I don't know I'm never committed to
memory
oh you think it's a soft I imagine it's
a soft horma why do you imagine that
because most names like that usually
have a soft J right Am I Wrong
um I think if they're uh Middle Eastern
or if they're
um Hispanic but
Jay like
let's put it to the test
let's see Roxy
I would say this is probably
drama
Dorma tomorrow
[Music]
because like you know within the other
way like
whatever and then the Jose or like like
an H
oh wait they do call him corpy in the
movie so yeah they do actually cite his
name oh that's what that was I kept
wondering if they actually said his real
name there the whole time well I think
this guy was a phenomenal performance
because he carries this movie without
saying any dialogue till the very end
and you you gotta communicate so much
just through your body language and your
expression and what I love too is even
though he is one of those this is this
is a hard thing you gotta capture with
an action movie like this this is where
like the Fast and Furious movies have
been failing for a lot of people is
there's no I haven't seen the latest one
so I can't attest to that one they've
all succeeded for me so I am not a good
test audience I think there's no Stakes
anymore oh my God the stakes are so high
because the stakes are family okay
well I think what is a bigger stake than
family you don't fear for Dominic
Toretto about to die you know you don't
feel for the danger they're in you don't
know that's true I don't I can't say
that about the latest Fast and Furious
we only have two left
um oh I can't wait
um well I think here when a character is
one where whenever he's in the room it
seems like he's gonna handle business
it's hard to still provide Stakes it's
still it's hard to make you still feel
the sense of danger that this guy is in
and I thought the movie actually did a
really good job at getting you to feel
the suspense of that situation without
without its undercutting him either that
I think that's a really really
impressive line to write in an action
totally because it's gonna feature the
whole time I fail himself and stuff yeah
theoretically it's a struggle yeah
theoretically he could have died in this
movie I didn't know that he was very
beginning of this movie right I didn't
know that he wasn't going to die at any
point you know like as he's getting this
the living [__] kicked out of him on the
plane I'm thinking to myself
maybe he dies and and that's like
one of the things about this and then
maybe like the plane goes down and the
gold is lost forever maybe he dies maybe
he makes it out but then he's going to
die so he gives all the gold to the
women maybe you know like in my head I'm
going through all the options and I
didn't feel 100 positive this man was
gonna make it out into the bank
but it also felt not realistic as in
like this movie is so realistic but it
didn't feel like that's egregious
because they set up this Legend around
him and I feel like they set these rules
in this world and then they played by
the roles that they set as long as it's
believable within the world that takes
place in you're fine right but it's like
he lived through a plane crash and I'm
not sitting here like oh come on because
it like yeah we saw him strapping I was
like yo homie's a fighter
we saw him we saw him in the water
taking out all the people bleeding up we
like that was crazy we saw him use
another man's neck for oxygen yeah I
want to look at the logistics of that
that'd be fun
it's a good Chase movie man do you
really want to look it up
I'll do it later do it right now okay I
want to do it right now all right I was
like I feel like I was changing the
subject I'm like I feel like she really
wants to look this up actually you're
all right that is a good Chase movie and
the people probably want to talk more
about that but what I need to know is
can you
and breathe
through it well because you know how
they like tricky people
to get them oxygen to their lungs yeah
yeah that's that with the pen
all right okay here here there's it's on
Reddit
okay never seen someone suck oxygen from
a slit throat before laugh my ass off uh
original ideas yeah
can we stick to the topic
okay okay doesn't oxygen turn into
carbon dioxide in the lungs after
inhaling it so he wouldn't have been
taking an actual oxygen rather carbon
dioxide no but it's before it goes to
the lungs right yeah this person's
answering yeah air is 21 oxygen wall the
air you exhale is 16 to 18 oxygen your
body is built with a lot of Reserve to
handle sub-optimal conditions so it only
requires a fraction of the oxygen in the
environment there's also a fair bit of
dead space in your mouth oh yeah in
there wow windpipes et cetera where no
oxygen is used one of the reasons mouth
to mouth resuscitation can work oh now
whether or not someone can gulp enough
air bubbles like Sonic and not get a lot
of water with it is a different question
uh-huh
and I'm more aware this guy's at you're
thinking about this movie too hard
I think you're right though yeah I
thought that part was sick that was
awesome I think this movie is gonna
definitely gain a big following I hope
so
and also it's a Chase movie
did you know that
it's a good chance they did a good job
too I love Keanu Reeves and John Wick
but [__] me sisu is nasty breathing from
a Dead Nazi throat [__] yeah
that's how I feel that's it yeah that's
exactly how I feel
well guys or would you rate it out of
10. well because of the Chase movie
aspect of it
I feel like that's like an 8.5 nice what
brings that what's the 1.5
that is not bring you to a 10.
um I think that
um like the
you're saying why isn't it perfect for
me yeah sure because I don't think this
move I think this was the best version
of this movie that they could do but a
10 movie for me like I know that this
isn't a 10 movie in general but for me
has like love
um which this lacked in certain ways you
know like a uh I I like like familial
relationships like parental
relationships love interests
um siblings things that connection and
this movie lacks
um connection with another human what's
uh what was the latest Fast and Furious
rating for you it's perfect it said it's
got all those things siblings yeah no no
no I mean is this a better movie than
that movie Yes do I love the fast
franchise yes but like if we're gonna do
this style movie this is as good as it
gets you know what is it for you
I'll give you like a 9 out of ten
why not a ten
um doesn't have like the brother
Dynamics it's the same as me like
doesn't have the family uh oh you're
making fun of me no I I got the oh so
you're making fun of me
I think uh
I'm not I'm not in I'm not entirely sure
what it was
um
it's like I was very much invested I
would say I was emotional I definitely
was emotionally invested
uh as much as I did like get pulled into
as much I was saying like I still get
pulled into the stakes and the danger
I would also weirdly say I didn't really
get pulled into the fear of the
situation and I could have used a little
bit of that I suppose would be a knit
picky be nitpicky man if you've got
enough nitpicks because yeah I think
that was one of the things that
I I was like such adoration not very
good uh I was in such Adoration of that
of them why did you say what's that I
must say it's a net uh but there's also
the like so much here that I'm that I
love about it and there's like this one
little percentage in my heart that I'm
like not quite clicking with
even though I feel like most of my heart
does and yeah I could have used a little
bit more of a
I don't know if I could have used it I
think there was a bit of an emotional
substance that I could have lashed
latched onto more than just the
immediate situation but then again the
immediate situation is a big part what
makes it brilliant this is like a Fury
Road meets Rambo you know yeah they did
make it more like
um theatrical like it's more not a
popcorn flick but it is more like
intense and less heartfelt yeah at times
uh what that heartfelt is the thing they
would go for no no that's what I'm
saying this is the best version of this
movie you can do exactly which is great
um did you pick up on the fact that this
was a really good solid Chase movie I
did about like 20 minutes into it I was
thinking oh that's interesting they've
been on the same road the whole time and
I can't wait to break that down with
Roxy would you call it a road trip film
yes
it's a buddy road trip
in a way it's what's this guy's name
what is his name scorpion the Nazis
that's what they should have called it
and I love that they have that at the
beginning and I like that term and I
feel like we should use that and I wish
we had a translation for it
why can't we just say Caesar we can I'm
just saying like they they said that
they can't translate so now in normal
day life I can't say CCU and how people
know what I'm talking about
well that's how you help normalize that
kind of terminology so you help
normalize The Finnish language in the
streets of Los Angeles so can you give
me any other word in Finnish
hmm
[Music]
or this is 95 on Rotten Tomatoes
bummer that hello is just High hey it's
hey hi hey that kimin that came I don't
know what those dots above the a mean
ah
all right
yes but it means
how do you think they used to sound and
then everyone's bored Rock and I think
thank you is ketos
well
well ketos to you guys at home oh nicely
done what that's how you transition
close us out Roxy all right you're gonna
want to do a couple different things
before you leave us Number One You're
Gonna Want to like if you haven't
already which why haven't you done it
you're going to want to leave a comment
because I read them all
no say something
um uh and and tixie and tixie say
something nice please antiquesy means
excuse me I guess in Finnish um and then
also if you're not already a patron
you're going to want to be one for the
next video because it's the best way to
see more of us in our entire reactions
and you might have missed it if you're
just here on YouTube and then um you're
going to want to follow the real rejects
which is just real rejects on social and
is that right yeah I thought we were you
said two things no it's a few things
okay all right and then um you're going
to want to tell Greg how happy you are
with me and then um you're gonna want to
fool you follow me one more did you say
Follow You Then You're Gonna Wanna
follow me at Roxy Strayer uh check me
out on the world girls and then thank
you so much uh we appreciate you coming
forget anything Greg okay goodbye or
more like not come in
okay look at how you say it knock knock
him in I'll look it up
[Music]